[Music]
[Applause]
this is a self-propelled sled it pulls
itself backwards this weighs about
35,000 lb as the Box moves forward it
increases the weight onto the pan Which
is here on the ground causing the driver
to go no further the sled will always
win it's got so much weight behind it
the mark of success here is as far
forward along the track as you can
get
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
today we've got a couple Vehicles here
having the vehicles fully charge matters
because that's when you have your Peak
power making sure they're all fully
charged really gets us on the same
playing field we wanted to bring not
just an eeve competitor so we also
looked at what is a great internal
combustion engine vehicle that's got
huge towing capacity and great
capability Tractive power is really how
much can you get that power from the
motor to the
ground truck pull is a Showcase of power
and attractive power of the truck and
that translates directly to on the road
Towing Towing your boat towing your
payload what we've designed the truck to
be is like really comfortable really
stable really powerful at high payloads
and that gives you the ability to be
confident on Road in order to make this
a really apples apples comparison we're
running them as they come straight from
the factory so stock tires they're
running at a curb weight plus driver a
heavier truck in this kind of event will
typically give you more momentum with
the truck itself so coming in here with
a truck that's one of the lightest in
this group if not the lightest and out
pulling everybody else really says
something about the capabilities of the
vehicle